У Німеччині за порушення правил дорожнього руху
забрати водійські права можуть навіть у пішохода.
Штрафи за перевищення швидкості регулярно підвищують.
Як саме карають за порушення ПДР у Німеччині?
Грошовий штраф для пішоходів, як правило, становить 5 євро.
Наприклад, за перехід у невстановленому місці або на червоне світло.
10 євро, якщо через дії пішохода сталася ДТП.
З огляду на середню зарплату в Німеччині такі штрафи - дріб'язок,
адже в західних землях ФРН у середньому заробляють
майже 3500 євро, а у східних - 2600.
Найсуворіше покарання - за перетин залізничної колії,
коли шлагбаум закритий чи напівзакритий.
Порушнику доведеться сплатити 350 євро та отримати 1 штрафний бал.
Крім того, у пішохода чи велосипедиста в Німеччині
можуть забрати водійські права, якщо він був нетверезий
і порушував правила дорожнього руху.
Водночас для захисту самих велосипедистів
запроваджено мінімальний бічний інтервал, якого водії
повинні дотримуватися під час обгону велосипедистів.
Всередині населених пунктів - 1,5 метра, а поза ними - 2 метри.
За недотримання цієї дистанції водієм штраф становить 30 євро.
У 2020 році в Німеччині почали діяти нові штрафи для водіїв.
Передусім посилили покарання за перевищення швидкості.
Приміром, удвічі збільшено штрафи за незначне перевищення швидкості.
20 євро доведеться сплатити за перевищення
до 10 кілометрів на годину поза населеними пунктами
і 30 євро - на території населених пунктів.
Крім того, і це одна з найсуттєвіших змін,
водійських прав тепер позбавляють на цілий місяць,
плюс штраф 95 євро і один штрафний бал,
якщо ви перевищили швидкість на 21-25 кілометрів у межах населених пунктів
і на 26-30 - поза ними.
А от покарання за перевищення на понад 60 кілометрів
у межах населених пунктів поки незмінно високе:
680 євро штрафу, 2 штрафні бали та позбавлення прав на 3 місяці.
До речі, в Україні штраф за перевищення швидкості
на понад 50 кілометрів становить в рази менше: 510 гривень.
У Німеччині карають порушників правил дорожнього руху
грошовими штрафами та штрафними балами, а також,
залежно від серйозності порушення, можуть
тимчасово заборонити керувати автоабо позбавити водійських прав.
Коли накопичується 8 балів, водійські права вилучаються.
Тоді доведеться робити нові, а це дорого і складно,
особливо якщо відправлять на проходження медично-психологічного обстеження,
яке в народі називають "тестом для ідіотів".
Разом із сеансами у психолога та іншими витратами
загальна вартість може перевищити тисячу євро.
Штраф 320 євро, позбавлення прав на місяць і два штрафні бали.
Саме таке покарання з 2020 року в Німеччині
за незаконний проїзд рятувальним коридором,
який мають створювати водії на дорозі,
щоб у випадку аварії пропустити швидку або поліцію.
Серед нових штрафів - і покарання у розмірі 100 євро плюс один штрафний бал,
якщо водій зупинився на спеціальних смугах для руху велосипедів.
Крім того, штраф за використання додатків, які попереджають про радари,
становить тепер 75 євро плюс один штрафний бал.
А за надмірне газування і створення зайвого шуму
чи за безцільну їзду туди-сюди можуть оштрафувати на 100 євро.